if you're like me you remember hitting
up blockbuster in the mid 90s and coming
across the
double vhs copy of stephen king's the
stand a six-hour epic i ironically
watched sitting down so when i heard cbs
all access or should i say no access if
you were trying to watch the super bowl
was making a completely new huge budget
full series adaptation i was like
oops sorry wrong clip in this video i
thought it would be fun to look at some
of the biggest differences between the
1994 version and
cbs's 2021 so put on your hazmat suits
and make sure to like and subscribe
because here we
go before we begin just a few words of
note this video won't be delving into
the over 1 000 page long book
partly because i can't read and i'll be
going pretty fast because there's a lot
to get to and even then i've left out
some of the differences just for time
but if you think i've left something
major out let me know in the comments
i'll also be referring to the 2020 2021
version as
cbs and the 1994 version as the
miniseries so other than the cbs
adaptation being shot almost 26 years
after the mini-series
cbs has nine hour long episodes and the
mini-series four
hour and a half long ones leaving the
cbs version with
three extra hours to tell the story and
even the way it's
told is different i actually preferred
the miniseries which told
everything chronologically starting with
june 17th the day the plague is
unleashed on earth
and ending on november 15. the cbs
version is all over the place including
multiple flashbacks and time jumps
making it difficult for those who aren't
familiar with the story to piece
together what really happened this
version takes place mainly in the fall
and winter as opposed to summer and fall
but that's
probably due in part to the shooting
schedule unlike the cbs version the
mini-series was written by stephen king
himself he even has a brief cameo
playing a character by the name of teddy
weizek a character who in the cbs
version is brutally shot to death and
bonus points for those of you who caught
steven in the background of this
poster in episode 4. so the story really
starts when a virus known as
captain trips escapes from a u.s
military base in both cases a guard
decides to escape
inadvertently spreading it into the
world you also notice the effects of the
virus in this cbs version
are really amped up showing huge bloated
necks
well the mini series they just kind of
popped some makeup and had people act
dead
in ogonquit maine we get our first look
at one of the most important characters
in the story
harold louder and damn they did this boy
dirty in the miniseries look at those
pimples in the cbs version they really
set him up as being a pervert and messed
up from the get-go which is why i prefer
the mini series here he's set up as the
lovestruck friend zone loser you kind of
feel sympathy for it's only until later
that he goes full
evil to show how different these two
versions are one need only look at the
screen time given to this character in
the first episode the first episode of
the cbs version
basically is dominated by this character
and his backstory while in the
miniseries he's only given one scene in
the entire hour and a half long episode
nick andros played by hunky dreamboat
rob lowe is given a latino makeover in
cbs and a more fleshed out backstory
where we see his eye gets gouged out in
a bar fight rob gets to keep his eye on
the miniseries
version probably because he's so
handsome in the mini-series he only
communicates via notepad but the cbs
version franny knows sign language and
acts as his interpreter
ed harris also has a brief cameo playing
general starkey the man responsible for
trying to cover
up the virus in his version he loves
poetry while in cbs's he's portrayed by
jk
simmons who has an affinity for
classical music meanwhile as the virus
spreads we meet larry underwood in new
york
a struggling singer-songwriter who only
cares about fame
i'm gonna be famous ma even better
i'm gonna be rich in the minix series he
teams up with a woman named nadine cross
the woman who will later become
series antagonist randall flagg's bride
for some reason this cbs version has him
team up with a woman who only appears
for about one or two episodes
and has no impact on the story but she's
played by heather graham
so there's that they team up to escape
manhattan in the cbs version they have
this whole
segment in the sewers while in the
mini-series they go through one of the
underground tunnels larry will end up
marrying a woman named lucy swann in the
mini-series a woman who has taken on
guardianship of a young boy named joe
lucy's character is cut from cbs and
nadine is the one who initially takes
care of joe in the mini-series
joe doesn't speak but he does in the cbs
version nadine is important because she
becomes randall flag's bride eventually
carrying his baby who he'll call his
prince and it's highly intimated that
this prince will be the prince of hell
the cbs nadine is pretty much
all in with randall from day one having
been chosen
and seduced by him when she was a child
in an orphanage a backstory we don't get
in the miniseries when nadine eventually
meets randall and they make love during
this weird
sexual assault type thing their
characters really start to differ in the
mini-series nadine goes crazy after
finding out how evil randall truly is
killing the baby insider by jumping off
the side of a building in the cbs
version nadine is put under some kind of
spell which makes her docile a spell
that is only broken when larry forces
her to see into her own reflection she
also grows this baby
almost a full term in about two days and
learns that randall never really cared
about her he was just using her as a
vessel for his child this prompts her to
also kill herself along with the baby
and let's not forget that pink scooter
franny played by molly ringwald in the
mini-series is straight up savage to
harold when he professes his love
you know maybe i could be harold we're
always gonna be friends
she'll go on to fall in love with stu
redmond an event which causes harold to
switch allegiances to randall
and we have to agree that harold's
jacket in the miniseries is totally
cooler the cbs version has this
terrifying trucker scene where the
trucker keeps
women chained in the back of his rig and
we see how cowardly herald is this scene
acts as an introduction of franny
meeting stew and is not in the
miniseries version
back in new york we're introduced to two
very minor characters who make
appearances in both versions
ratman and monster shouter portrayed by
nba great kareem abdul-jabbar in the cbs
version he's replaced with a white dude
who says he's going to masturbate in
yankee stadium while ratman's role is
significantly expanded through the
character of
rat woman who is in charge of
entertainment at flag stronghold a huge
casino in vegas called inferno in the
mini-series his casino is called
union plaza and is located in old vegas
not the main strip
all of these characters experience
dreams from two people
randall flagg and mother abigail mother
abigail in the miniseries is said to be
106 while in cbs she's 108. like that
makes a difference hemingford home the
location abigail asked the survivors to
meet her
is her home in nebraska while in the cbs
version it's an
actual old folks home also in nebraska
whereas mother abigail encapsulates
everything good in the world
randall flag is the opposite his version
in the miniseries is more over the top
and cocky while alexander skarsgards for
the most part
is subdued making the moments he does
lash out even more frightening in the
miniseries we never really see what
happens to randall flang after the
nuclear explosion that supposedly kills
him we're to assume that he's dead
however the cbs version
sees him still alive trying to tempt
franny and eventually taking over a
small remote indigenous tribe as their
god we see a new version of mother
abigail as well
much younger suggesting that the fight
for good and evil will never
end and that's something the cbs version
does that the mini-series doesn't
a full episode dedicated to the events
after the nuclear bomb goes off in vegas
speaking of the nuclear bomb how could
we forget beloved trashcan man well his
character is a mess in both versions
both physically
and his motivations in cbs they cut out
this whole side story of him sabotaging
the plane that was supposed to drop
bombs on mother abigail's camp his story
is more streamlined in cbs
and culminates in him bringing a nuke to
the casino in the mini-series this weird
hand of god comes out and
explodes the nuke while in cbs it's a
billowing cloud of lightning that does
it
our introduction to lloyd henry the man
who will become randall's right-hand man
is also different in the mini-series he
resorts to eating a rat in his jail cell
to survive while he straight up dines on
his cellmate's leg in the cbs version
cbs's interpretation of lloyd has him
over the top and reckless while in the
miniseries he's much more reserved and
professional oh boy next up is tom
cullen whose 1994 version
portrayed by the same guy who voices
patrick and spongebob
probably wouldn't be allowed on tv
nowadays i always forget stuff like that
i hate being [ __ ] in the cbs version
he willingly agrees to become a spy
while in the mini-series he has to be
hypnotized in the mini-series he gets a
job as a laborer at the airfield while
in cvs's he's part of a janitorial crew
responsible for taking away the bodies
in the gladiator ring as the survivors
congregate in boulder colorado to start
a new life there are a number of
differences
like how we actually see the power plant
in the miniseries or how harold gets a
hold of the explosives
that will eventually blow up mother
abigail's home in the mini-series he
just kind of finds them with the help of
randall but the cbs version does a
better job here when harold finds out
that this ski patrol would use
explosives to create controlled
avalanches
in cbs harold and nadine both press the
button setting off the explosives
together
while in the mini-series it's only
herald the cbs version adds some more
mystery when a vegas survivor of flags
sends a warning to the town
something that doesn't happen in the
miniseries the town committee decides
that they need to send out three
spies to see if randall is planning an
attack here are the differences between
these two versions the notable one here
being the judge changing from an older
black man to an older white woman we
don't see how the judge dies in the cbs
version but we see the shootout he's
involved in in the miniseries in both
versions dana attempts to kill randall
but in the mini series her knife turns
into a banana in cbs she manages to stab
him in the neck but it has no effect on
him along with his power he has the
ability to levitate which we don't see
in the mini-series version and he can
also melt skulls
on his way to join randall harold's
motorcycle veers off course and he gets
into a terrible accident
[Applause]
nadine watches by and does nothing to
help him hello up there
i'm still alive but i'm very badly
injured i think my legs might be broken
he'll later go on to write a note on his
body saying i was misled
stu also has this shining like power
where he senses that harold has been
killed but that's cut from the cbs
version and
never really even explored in the
miniseries harold also dies in a
motorcycle accident in cbs however it's
nadine who causes it by making him speed
up too fast
in this version harold leaves an entire
notepad owning up to all the pain he's
caused
in the mini-series mother abigail and
randall never really talk
they do in cbs when she ventures off
into the forest to listen to god when
she returns from her journey it's
joe who finds her whereas in the
mini-series she just kind of stumbles
back one night
on her deathbed mother abigail says she
has a message from god that four people
must go to vegas to confront flag
with nothing but the clothes on their
backs the crew is the same in both
versions with the exception of
ralph who is swap with rey glenn who we
haven't covered yet is markedly older
than his counterpart
in the cbs version his paintings become
a plot point in cbs while they're not
really covered in the miniseries while
his death in both versions are done at
the hands of lloyd in the mini-series
he's killed in a cell after getting
captured
and the cbs version he's put on a show
trial where he prods lloyd until he
snaps the whole show trial scene
doesn't happen in the miniseries and
even the final execution scene is
different in the mini-series larry and
ralph are the final two survivors and
are strung up on these weird devices
awaiting their deaths
in the cbs version they're tied to an
empty pool which also doubles as the
gladiator pit and slowly drowned
after the nuke explodes the mini-series
basically ends tom saves stew from the
brink of death as the angel of nick
andros helps him find out the right
medication to heal him after a terrible
fall left him stranded on the way to
vegas the whole angel nick thing never
happens in the cbs version however we do
get an entire episode dedicated to what
happens after the blast
which honestly was completely
unnecessary stew and franny
risked their lives with their like
three-month-old baby to travel back to
maine just because franny wanted to see
the ocean again and franny almost dies
by falling down a well if you ask me
they should have just ended it with stu
coming back to be reunited with his wife
and baby
also the 90s version has these cool
vignette montage sequences of all the
people that died during the course of
the show which is just so 90s and i'm a
little bitter they didn't do it in this
one so that's it for some of the
differences between
both versions of the stand what did you
think of the show and what version do
you think is superior leave your
thoughts and comments in the description
below
thanks for watching everyone please make
sure to like and subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much